[Musique]
c'était le 25 décembre 2021 à kourou en
guyane française c'est beaucoup beaucoup
d heures de travail pour des années de
travail et tout s'est joué à ce moment
précis
la fusée ariane 5 lancée dans l'espace
le télescope le plus puissant jamais
construit
mais après on a encore quelques minutes
jusqu'au la séparation c'est presque
deux minutes à tâtonner vraiment chaque
étape est très était très important
successeur du télescope hubble le james
webb du nom d'un ancien patron de la
nasa est un bijou de technologie le
fruit de trente ans de recherches
une mission à 10 milliards de dollars
c'est comment on crie salines
qui est fini pour déployer le sel qui a
finalement un beau papillon
le james webb il a été fabriqué plus de
dix ans après donc on a des nouvelles
technologies en plus il est bien plus
large donc il va pouvoir récolter
beaucoup plus de lumière qui provient de
bien plus loin dans l'espace
l'avantagent de l'espace parlera pour
faire de la soirée c'est extraordinaire
l'espace parce que
depuis le sol les scop qui marche très
bien mais l'atmosphère turbul toujours
il ya toujours du vent il ya toujours
des effets thermiques ne sorte que les
images au lieu d'être parfaitement
précise et sont déformés sont floues un
peu
dans les années 80 pieds abelli
travaille à la conception de télescopes
dans l'un des centres de la nasa
quant à eux les mises en orbite à 600 km
de la terre son directeur lui demande de
plancher déjà sur un télescope nouvelle
génération bien plus performant
si pierre pense d'abord à un télescope
optique capable de capter la lumière
visible ses recherches lui font bientôt
changer d'avis
on force est de concevoir
voilà ce qui s'est passé c'est que qui a
eu une conférence kate est fondamentale
cette conférence qui a eu lieu en 1989
où on s'est rendu compte que non on veut
pas faire c'est simple c'est parce qu'on
veut on veut pas fait des scores plus
grande qui marche dans la non l'optique
dans le domaine optique on peut
intéresser aux petits marche dans
l'infrarouge
l'infrarouge est une ode invisibles à
l'oeil nu mais perceptible par des
instruments sensibles à la chaleur
il ya plein de raisons pour laquelle les
astronomes et les scientifiques ont
envie de regarder l'univers dans
l'infrarouge il ya par exemple le fait
que dans l'espace la lumière qui se
propagent ces tirs avec l'univers
lui-même avec ce qu'on appelle
l'expansion de notre univers ce qui fait
que de la lumière qui pouvait être
visible à une époque en étant étiré
devient invisible à nos yeux parce
qu'elle est de l'infrarouge le télescope
james webb va permettre de voir ses
premières lumières qui ont été émises
par les premières étoiles et donc de
remonter dans l'histoire de notre
univers beaucoup plus loin que ce qu'on
a réussi à faire jusqu'à présent
pendant trente ans la nasa travaille à
fabriquer un télescope sensible à
l'infrarouge
problème la terre et le soleil émettent
de la chaleur qui pourrait gêner ces
captations pour l'en empêcher
un bouclier ep de cinq couches grand
comme un court de tennis et placé sous
les miroir du télescope
les communications avec la terre se fait
partout les six romans qui sont dans les
bus du satellite qui sont partis l'accès
côté terre et l'observation des étoiles
s'est faite d'un autre côté qui est
protégé du soleil par ses clients
pour réaliser une telle prouesse
technique la nasa a collaboré avec
l'agencé spatiale canadienne et l'
agence spatiale européenne qui a fourni
deux des quatre instruments de james
webb ainsi que le lanceur la fusée
ariane 5
pour le lancement de ce télescope on a
besoin des deux critères principaux en
c'était la performance de dire la
possibilité d'envoyer la masse de ce
télescope qui était un peu plus de 6
tonnes vers les points des transferts à
lesquelles il devait y aller et puis un
volume très important c'est un ace que q
pendant la très grande et donc en volume
à l'intérieur de la coiffe et donc il
avait très peu des lanceurs dans le
monde qui permettait d'avoir ces
critères
après son déploiement de l'espace le
james webb a poursuivi sa route jusqu'à
son orbite
il se trouve actuellement au point de
lagrange 2 à 1 million et demi de
kilomètres de la terre
d'eau soleil et face à l'univers profond
l'étude de l'atmosphère de planètes
lointaines peut potentiellement
né des indices quant à l'existence de
d'activité biologique peut-être de vie
sur cette planète lointaine ça on n'a
quasiment jamais on n'a pas d'instrument
qui à la sensibilité pour nous permettre
de voir ça aujourd'hui gm souhaite va
ouvrir une porte sur la détection de vie
extraterrestre
une porte vers le futur et une meilleure
compréhension des origines de l'univers
c'est la mission de ce télescope
révolutionnaire
[Musique]